both stop streaming when I'm about to
sleep well stop sleeping when I'm about
to stream that'll teach you go play I
could play should I play tell me what to
do let me do a strawpoll what to do
bullets and viewer challenges hey it's a
sub so laga Thor gets an extra two votes
for subbing and saying arena oh its hide
so lagna Thor might be the tiebreaker 20
votes Wow
and it's just tied I posted it pretty
early on so not too many people are here
I guess I'm gonna play the arena 14 to
11 I was thinking viewer challenges I
was going to win in a landslide so what
I'll do I'll do the arena and then I'll
do viewer challenges afterwards to
please some people okay Oh does twitch
have a polling system built-in maybe huh
well too late now okay so I'm gonna turn
this off never at least for the never
for the next whatever 60 minutes oh but
these challenges still remain oh so if
you challenge me and you want to play in
like an hour
leave your challenge open if I'm joining
the tournaments I swap the poll open oh
yeah the the Eastern bullet arena is
still winning by one vote it's 16 to 15
good job chats okay let's do this bullet
chess having spooned bullet chess in a
while what is this b7 on your key hey
Pitt show good morning or good evening
probably good morning to you you're
probably in Europe whoa it's just a
flick with a real
what's up chef athletic I was watching
your stream
oh dear I'm losing a pawn
I was watching her stream yesterday or
the day before and it seemed like your
first stream and you weren't able to
figure out the chats and I messaged you
on my chest but I don't think you saw it
oh is that excise sparks also I'm
getting smashed because I'm down upon
white has a bishop pair but Knights are
actually more valuable in bullets I
think oh this is very uncomfortable free
pawn no mmm everything in life is free
but not that pawn tell me okay I'm
getting smashed even more this is really
bad I might lose the first game my
beautiful beautiful rating it's about to
take a dip actually close to my peak all
I want to do is peek what to do maybe
the smooth absolute Lord bishops Queen
be a tricky move please miss Queen g3
please
that's scary very scary ooh okay less
scary maybe more scary for white now I'm
about to fork now to get my forking
revenge hmm maybe flagging revenge is
the best type of revenge free pawn
what's a bishop doing on g8 this is also
a really slow time scramble we were
moving in slow motion which isn't great
for bullets oh let me give a shout out
chess athletic liveried people should
check him out and follow him new to
streaming but not new to chess
international master who beat me a long
time ago in chess at the u.s. Junior
closed 2012 maybe I almost suppressed in
memory hmm okay hello two more people
I am Nastasia or is it did I say that
right Nastasia I don't know I tried
welcome does someone know my oh yeah my
peak pull rating is 2800 a good job
Johnny DJ for knowing that Japanese
tutor welcome John welcome even though I
already said hi to John how old am I I'm
older than like every teenager on the
planet but younger than most Heder most
senior citizens okay let's go back to
tournament that was only one game I was
such a long bullet game okay time to
drink tea I'm actually impressed chess
off leg knows how to read because when I
first started streaming I didn't know
how to rage for the first several weeks
mantan atlet's okay ooh I could berserk
let's hold off on booze irking for now
though I'll just do something
before four nights Center for trick well
impeccable Kim yeah I got your design I
don't know if I want to like have roses
be my brand kind of maybe step away from
flowers as an identifier to a little
dogs whoa it's 900 bits an episode of
uncertainty with slight sprinkles of joy
thanks Danny wizard or thinks are we
supposed to but maybe the same person
okay II for let's play oh you for just
gives away a pawn what does it I don't
know about to meet yeah I'm about to
meet or not or maybe I don't know okay
I'm gonna keep attacking stuff my pieces
are nice house a nice free pawn subsided
formula thanks for bits thanks for
getting me into chess and teaching it so
well oh well thank you for existing play
this one about to meet now hard for back
to the fence yeah okay so two out of two
not the cleanest games but it could be
worse what do you see your brand as I
don't know tea calmness what to do let's
position
okay I'm risking a lot of reading here
but I've I'm confident subsided formula
thanks for subbing Oh gifted by John we
have a Dutch Dutch Dutch in honor of
John and all the other Dutch people play
this move okay so I'm 26 seconds I can't
get you distracted everyone this is
Alexa Oh
Alexa's been sleeping for a while now
dying that nice winter hibernation Oh
Alex Alexa woke up I think maybe I
forgot I plugged you back in okay let's
play this move
let's play this move oh dear haha
alright push up g3 I'm down a lot of
time what's with my time I guess I
deserved play a6 I want to Queen the
pawn eventually the best way to Queen
upon is to push up on don't Mimi who
don't meet me oh no I'm getting needed
no only missed it though oh wow
g2 is hanging don't laugh at me laugh
with me
in rosandjohn flag it's a miracle it's a
miracle it's a miracle it's a miracle
well the game oh yeah what is that it's
it's declared a win because I have a
bishop black and somehow the goats yeah
don't really eat goats but I'm trying to
emulate a goat sometimes yeah it's a win
because black can go in the corner go in
the corner with the Knights under
promotes maybe another night and then I
can check meats somehow yeah okay well
it's kind of what happened in the
Carlsen fruga world blitz championship
so I got my buzzer 'king points Alexis
Simon Says Eric is a legend have you
heard that
Alexis being very quiet Alexis said and
someone named Eric is a legend all right
i but let's not bezerk again that was
too stressful that was way too stressful
I'm still shaking kind of I take here I
think I can take there and then go for a
mate maybe maybe not
oh no maybe go for Forks looks nice
my night might get trapped that's the
nature of being in the corner well does
this move okay I'm happy to trade happy
to castle just have to be happy about
things in life yeah I'm very happy the
brook is smiling the night has a friend
and I can now escape what does this move
free Bishop yeah let's not get neither
oh my nights my beautiful nights I have
Brooke f7 coming or not yeah let's just
take a thing and I'll move the night
back yeah okay that was nice okay
staying clean and trying my best really
trying dime at you okay
ooh hi radio so I actually have to kind
of stay focused skiing c5 I got tricked
until I can normal London hmm okay let's
be aggressive Oh Queen III is a nice
smooth whoa it's a big raid
that's a nice raid Ben Feingold how's it
going also been flying gold people how's
it going I assume most of your people if
you're just joining I'm playing I'm
playing bullet chess don't usually do
this I'm trying my best
a little bit flustered for multiple
reasons
don't hurry mom
hmm I'll play this move
I just want to trade Queens and not get
needed mm-hmm
opponents making life difficult let's
move
always retreats Ben would be proud maybe
it's not hang upon oh dear don't Mimi oh
I got forts that's a good fork - this is
brutal night each one so sad
I have 11 seconds what I didn't even
berserk okay let's try and fight back
pawn storm time die flagged oh I'll play
them - oh that's rough that's so rough
hi - Karen thanks for stopping by
also John gifting a sub to Ben that was
really rough III was just slow too weak
maybe too old
what to do I was too flustered - okay
but I have a bishop hair I'm playing by
a five preparing Bishop before I lost a
pawn but it's okay Queenie seven coming
doom why am I so bad at chess a point
delayed like taking that just probably
being confused I do have a rule if
possibilities
mmm I've multiple raclette possibilities
yeah so King D when I have 36
let's keep Queens on the board
rooks are finding life I've lost a pawn
but weight doesn't take it okay that's
nice man
I feel slow something like ruined my
confidence but okay
maxxium I'm regaining confidence works
are finding happiness play rook h4 only
down oh man
wait why am i dropping stuff I keep
dropping stuff okay let's drop the
bishop at least mm yeah go for this sort
of idea I want to take nexts it doesn't
work I have to go for the dirty flag to
pull another miracle
don't fork me place move okay
dirty flag I feel bad but I also feel
kind of good all right on top top 1000 I
have to take down the diner Matt what is
that dime at the to dyma - okay whoa
it's just we've another red second read
no it's a third grade
it's a third grade this tournament
thanks so much chess we'd also shout-out
to the weave someone can use the weave
commands we have special command for the
one the only choice we've okay the goal
is to attack I want to play h5 and break
through maybe there's a baby - first I'd
Bishop g5 but that's okay we need to
check check always council locks was
stuck oh that was tricky I was very
tricky but I'm tricky - oh oops am i
doing okay this is good enough
to tournament okay let's go six place
have some catching up to do
I've only lost one game could be a lot
worse
yeah shout out to the weave I'll use the
week here and again the club is good
it's busy long busy days but it's fun
okay Stafford gambit time let's go
I want to play night here late Queen a
five I'll lift the rook to or maybe not
they rook here d5 very ambitious ooh
Oh thankfully my Queen defends Erick
it's a miracle but I lose pawns mm-hmm
you're simply Queenie five looks solid
and this move does that trap the Queen
kind of because the Queen here I have
Bishop a to I mean why could take I'm
still worse but getting some imbalance
don't make me oh that's a tricky move I
can't take the night I played this move
I just want to take on c2
hmm oh that would be a blunder I do this
and there's this
have to be very careful here what to do
check
okay I have to go for the dirty flag
again or the dirty pin five coming doe
it's a dirty Fork aha
oh that's sad it's kind of sad
losing rating points my own speed I
could be faster yeah not on the great
showing so far let's try and fight back
f4 I'm tilted now I have to force myself
to play faster take and go for amides
hey it's a sub ranch do boy thanks for
subbing that sounds French but also kind
of American I'm gonna play this move for
some reason Wow I'm one trade away from
quadruple pawns do I have any solution
check the other yellow one of double
Brooks I guess I'm fighting made in for
one okay it's five one two three four or
five I don't know this is such a nice
meat did this meat that take stuff along
the rink okay
yeah ranch sounds American Du Bois
sounds French
I didn't get my quadruple pawns acting
but I got my meat Oh Brian Brian was
here but had the time on mutes never
leave the tab on mutes oh it was
probably on mute because because I was
hosting been mangled huh yeah you should
be careful also opponent should be
careful yeah this is a great position
already I'm up a rock
soon to be up another pawn move move in
my bishops getting trapped
I mean yeah it's kind of trapped what to
do let's just give it up I'm still up a
up the exchange I guess Chuck Chuck
Chuck okay that's good enough
I'm blocks trying to confuse me it's
kind of working to one win this pond now
I should always play King be one again
I'm getting confused
let's move just want to take on g4 there
we go hey it's tog II oh it's a tag
emotes but not the real tog II it's cheb
ASCO welcome back ok so I have 15 points
to catch up diamond the two lost the
first game lots of time yeah so this is
a nice line this is um fun line to play
a tail take Bishop e6 so I have the
bishop hair mean White has a solid
position bring the rook to e8 this pawn
is very tender maybe maybe some g5 I'm
off coming whoo it was nice of white
okay that was very nice
I need more quick wings like that I'm
pretty sure tog II was like I'm on some
adventure and my vegan only sometimes
but most days I I break my vegan ISM one
way or another okay let's not lose the
scheme
so Bishop g4 this is a fun line the last
time we had the bishop here with Bishop
d6 Bishop a6 just wins this is great
open preparation Queen b6 I guess I can
take and then trade and this is very
comfortable the night here
they got three h4 just try and drop the
Bishop g5 this is so nice it still takes
work though okay let's take a nasty five
is a week hmm
I'm blocks actually playing well here
I'm probably gonna sack the exchange and
just go for the pawn majority okay this
is a risky decision but I think it's
okay oh it's not okay oh this is not
okay why did I do this I have this
smooth thing for you maybe it's okay
oh maybe it's not okay FF 5 coming don't
hurt me
okay I'm gonna Queen with Chuck that's
nice
let's go I was kind of but I was much
better than I was maybe worse and then I
think I was losing and then I was better
again that I was winning
I'm he almost flagged but then I made it
okay hey I took down first place and now
I'm playing some person good luck to my
opponents oh I'm so starstruck Oh what
to do this is so flustering let's take
and play d5 I guess hmm I think I'd want
to play f6 I I have a worse position but
maybe it could be even worse yeah I'm
just trying to hold on okay we can trade
happy with all the trades cuz I'm
running a pawn yeah I'm just trying to
be solid the h5 bring the night
somewhere maybe maybe not play this move
hey it's bits
let's go Jam I'm trying but which champ
cuz I'm playing a champ what to do here
I'll play this move
after 300 strong the baby week pong I
have this moment what you just described
about that last game is how almost all
of my 10-minute games go
yeah that's life haha I'm up 10 seconds
that's nice
okay haha I think I'm better here
it better be better I want my pawns who
i blundered upon lee what to do I have
to walk around I don't want to walk oh
well what to do what to do now he's so
tricky let's go okay oh man that was
close
good game good end game I was really
close
palms are sweating I'm spaghetti okay
I had spaghetti earlier although garnet
is very Hardy no leads
Oh lead schoo okay well you have a Dutch
touch okay kind of ducked earlier so at
the Dutch I like the setup with this
stuff found in queenside castle maybe
h3g for ooh I'm getting forked I've
shown this idea to students to should
listen to myself when I talk play this
move it's not great but okay my rating
should be some form of compensation in
Bishop c4 coming
yeah it's interesting because my knight
does stuff if my Knights taken my rook
will do stuff I still want to play g4
wow that nights annoying okay always
play King b1 there's might have seven to
some idea can pre move this never mind
Oh what to do I really didn't want to
play that move that's such a sad move
I'm about to get meted this is really
bad so I have to go for a dirty flag is
this while I'm meeting I'm meeting
I'm also flagging yeah okay fogging my
opponents let's go
Wow I'm close I'm close to first I was a
really close game I could have easily
lost that yeah Olive Garden is
overpriced except when it's catered for
free anyway I'm playing ask chess let's
play it's like a 3d of some swords
oh well what to do what to do I kind of
like this possession I have some
pressure play Negi sudden usually you
shouldn't castle on the side where you
push your each pawn not too late now
pressure the e-file play d5 if you 5 I
have 905 and bishops about to get route
we're not
Oh know what to do that's life I'm c5
may be coming your knight of 5
I want to play c4 I don't know what's
going on okay I'm attacking all the
pawns
now pawns are crumbling look at two it
was very close to meet now kind of I'm
not meeting I'm guess I'm not meaning it
was close to meet where's the meat
there's a small that's good enough
this is a nice threat which can't really
be stopped
let's go okay I'm still in seconds but
I'm trying to catch up I have my streak
beautiful streak beautiful sub give me
shelter
I'll give you shelter and less on your
opponent's znation welcome back okay
time for more tea more than halfway
through we have just under 25 minutes
left you don't have a garden in Scotland
I'm sure you have olive gardens okay
let's play d4 we're just gonna stay
solid yeah solid opening I like the
Queen on b1 it prevents Knight e4 I play
a floor Bishop h4 this is all typical
London stuff h3 maybe g4 coming soon
okay so I win a pawn this is very nice I
just want to put all the pieces on the
Kings side and take all the pawns
yeah the rooks overworked places it's
too over words I'll dance around for a
little bit
wait what about losing in first place Oh
second place is the first loser yeah but
it's also the second winner
Wow I'm looking so many pawns okay that
was nice hey I won Connect four before I
could draw the arrow Oh first place
keeps winning it's gonna be a close
finish how much tea do you go through in
a week I mean today I had I don't know
the three or four cups so far oh the
Queen e2 person I remember this person
yeah so I look insane I don't know you
tell me don't tell me there's someone
can tell me a good win Kinect for again
deserves more laughs I always play King
mediates I wanted to do something but
the battery looks nice I want to do
damage hmm where's my damage does it
make sense to open the position I have
the bishop here
I have a small time advantage okay I'm
not sure who that trade benefitted I'll
play queenie does that move ah that's a
move could still play this defending the
Knights preparing rookie three don't
Queenie for coming yeah just going for
the flag okay let's go and first place
keeps winning I might need to start
buzzer King at some points chess BAE
what's up Jessup a welcome back
play the scotch game no I think I'll
hold off on scotch for a little bit I'll
stick with my tea mmm oh this is very
very key matchup this is first place if
I win this game I'll have good chances
if I lose this game I'll have bad
chances
I think b5 is still playable so I
wouldn't be too icy for Brooke before if
that I do this no I don't do that
maybe I don't know what to do here
Queenie seven that's complicated don't
entirely know what's going on oh now I
know what's going on this is not good
for me this is really not good I'm
trying to apply some pressure that's a
good move oh this is really bad
have to try to fight this is really bad
[Music]
Mon hey Luce oops
yes let's go let's go it declares a win
again because I have a bishop one
bishops enough to win dirty flag let's
go
I survived this one thinking oh I'm
shaking shaking oh so much pressure
let's go what to do that's one a voice I
didn't realize a rule I have such a tone
sometimes the points playing a hippo
time to hunt the hippo or let's go
Bishop e5 hmm probably not h3 ooh
have to be careful here I don't know
what to do dirty five I'm getting
slightly outplayed hmm it's not too bad
or maybe in this planet I don't know I
think that guy first we thought after
the game that's possible I want to win a
pawn or that pawn it was really generous
of my opponents to give me a free Queen
oh I'm getting pinned it's okay I still
have an extra queen I'm a little bit
down on time Louie five coming I see
three firsts me the spear coming oh no
no no no no no no I wanted to play c4
not Queen takes d4 Oh
to work to win this one now what is
going on actually kind of coming back
rather quickly
about to get mated though hmm that's a
bit exotic this is not good please get
forked please please thank you thank you
I always say thank you when you receive
gifts thanks so much
I was a messy game the longer this goes
the Messier gets but I'm in first place
that's what now there's 15 minutes left
let's go only by one point though I have
to stay strong
I have to stay very strong okay ooh
buzzer Keable is our time
boat s gambit for the win
let's go completely 4v4 is a typical
idea like we need to maybe free Brooke
that's nice thank you
whoo free pawn thank you Queen c2 okay
going for the kill
so nice move I've three attackers
against off seven let's go
got the berserk win some nice juicy five
points I've only lost one game I guess
I've had so many like clothes dirty
games feels like I've lost more okay
fourteen minutes go Karen go Jerry
wait no knock Oh Jerry what to play play
this stuff again
Oh Jerry knows what to do what to do is
so tricky we have the same opening as
last time kind of I don't know what to
do here maybe this move in 94 now this
is not turning out well maybe squares
are so weak it's Queen rook b8 I guess
okay I'm happy about that
Bishop f8 that's a reasonable position
keep training because e5 is kind of weak
keep trading some more I want to bring
the key
I'm the rook belongs on a four maybe a
five I don't know what I'm doing I
should push pawns that's a good move I'm
in big trouble here no oh good job Gary
oh those are rough ah you play the
ending well what did you
well I'm tied for first but just let my
lead slip diamond diamond too is coming
back oh this is gonna be a very close
finish I have to stay strong mentally
and physically the London I'm trying I'm
trying witness no bishop what does
Bishop III okay at least no Bishop h6 is
so bad it's brightening night up sex
there this was such a bad opening I was
really bad
hmm have to make up for it okay try
those confusing my opponent needy maybe
not
please just be confused yes okay that
you six pawns of surviving somehow
please move your knight please
so be such a nice move you seven check
yes let's go I think it works right it's
better work yeah I'm winning everything
Wow I turned around I was down the piece
but now I'm up a rook and a pawn thank
you thanks for all the ponds and the
Knights so generous let's go you seven
so clutch okay that was crucial because
I can't keep losing games am I gonna
play Jerry again I feel like I'm gonna
play Jerry no Jerry is still playing
okay playing the gravel it's dangerous I
know I for what is f for what is this
what is this takes what this is it's so
weird I'm attacking this and meet
okay this is reasonable I'm up to
bishops and the pawn actually pawns are
equal but life is good life is very good
what's not bad dream just go for meat
I'm g5 is always useful it's close to
meet it's very close mmm where's the
meat not seeing it okay there's a flag
okay a berserk win that's nice
did it give me points oh it gave me
points I'm in first place
let's go eight minutes left place for
just have to stay focused and strong I'm
always [ __ ] be more intuitive pong
sack just want to do this stuff
actually if queenside castle I take the
Knights and then actually maybe I don't
take the Knights mmm
you're just simplifying maybe wasn't the
best decision I have a very pleasant
time advantage bring the king de coeur
maybe then the night belongs here maybe
not sure what I'm doing I'm doing
something should be sudden I have this
move I don't know what that does
I just moved coming that should be
winning now let's go okay 72 points have
a streak ever talk to Alexa again wait
ill or all or I will okay uh playing the
water lily sounds non-threatening but
have to be careful
I think yeah let's okay can go for a
nice square yeah I'm just going for the
nice pawn hmm that's a good move but you
can just take and take everything I
probably shouldn't have castled but it's
simple oh I had Queen d3 just winning
yeah active rook up a pawn about to win
another pawn thank you tricky I'm
winning all the paws thank you let's
push up on let's go join whoo okay I
have a nice little cushion 76 points and
my hands are cold now and here were
sweaty moments ago okay
I have we have four minutes left about
playing PML male ok let's play
interesting go play d5 yeah
92 am I losing a pawn I think I'm losing
upon maybe not on xe4 hey it's a sub
it's just ups simultaneous subs what to
do here in this move rook d1 let's take
41 Queen D 3 I don't know what to do
turning something it's very confusing
position I think I'm just up upon I
could have taken 2 but this is
reasonable
that's a scary move I'm not getting
mated thankfully oh boy
hey 10-point cushion I might actually
win this the chest network could still
berserk win two in a row to be careful I
think I started the tournament like 27
10 27 81 I'm not sure Pete's a racer oh
dear good games okay let's finish off
round Todd you taki taki taki taki
Hugh's gonna have you tied be conscious
for target this is position hmm was
working was probably a bad idea but
trying to finish in style I was a very
generous gift
I just want to trade and simplify and
maybe you want to pawn
yeah I want to win this before the
terminals am i not winning this wait how
I win this to come around with the
bishop there we go
there's almost a drop Wow
let's go
Wow well the tournament's I didn't think
I was gonna win like maybe 15 minutes
ago
but I had some handsome nice victories
Alexa play goodbye forever
is that your your finish Alexa louder
also people watching in the future on
YouTube thanks for watching
oh don't search YouTube but people on
YouTube I hope you enjoyed that feel
free to leave a comment like the video
Alexa's actually searching YouTube Alexa
you can leave a comment - maybe yeah
thanks you two people for watching I'll
see you in the future